O
STAND UP TO HELP US.
JOANNE A REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF
THE NEW YORK CITY COUNCIL AND
HER DISTRICT SITS RIGHT NEXT
DOOR TO TIFFANY CABAN.
SO, TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
OUR FRIEND TIFFANY.
I MEAN, IS SHE AS CRAZY AS SHE
APPEARS ON THOSE VIDEOS?
>> SHE IS ABSOLUTELY THE
ABOLITIONIST, THE
OBSTRUCTIONIST, AND THE CHAOS
INCITER THAT YOU SAID SHE WAS.
SHE IS ABSOLUTELY ALL THOSE
THINGS.
AND SHE IS ALSO A HYPOCRITE.
>> Jesse: SHE CALLS THE POLICE
AFTER TELLING US WE CAN'T CALL
THE POLICE IF WE ARE ABOUT TO BE
STABBED.
DO YOU THINK SHE HAS THE BRAIN
POWER TO UNDERSTAND HOW INSANE
AND HYPOCRITICAL SHE SOUNDS?
RIGHT.
IMPORTANT TO PUT UP A TWEET SHE
DIDN'T CALL THE POLICE.
SHE HAD -- SHE CALLED THE
COUNCIL AND THE COUNSEL SKILL
SECURITY WHO THEN CALLED THE
POLICE.
I THINK THAT'S JUST SPLITTING
HAIRS.
ALL SHE WANTS TO DO IS DO AS I
SAY AND NOT AS I DO THE VERY
WEEK SHE PUT OUT THAT FLIER THAT
YOU PUT UP ON DID I GO TO HIGH
SCHOOL WITH YOU OR THROW A SODA
FOR DISTRACTION?
THAT WAS THE VERY WEEK THAT
ALISON ROUSSEAU LOST HER LIFE.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT A TRAINED
FIRST RESPONDER COULD HAVE
SURPRISED AND STABBED IN HER
NECK FIVE TIMES AND NOW THE
FAMILY AND NEW YORK MOURNS HER.
>> Jesse: HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUTS I
DON'T THINK THAT LINE IS GOING
TO WORK VERY WELL.
YOU KNOW THIS DISTRICT THAT SHE
REPRESENTS TO THE PEOPLE IN HER
DISTRICT WANT TO EMPTY THE
PRISONS.
>> CONSTITUENTS THAT BELIEVE
THAT I ALSO THINK THERE IS A
VERY LARGE GROUP OF CONSERVATIVE
DEMOCRATS LIVE IN ASTORIA AND
SURROUNDING AREA OF HER DISTRICT
THAT DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
>> HOW CAN WE EMPTY RIKERS
ISLAND.
WE JUST RECENTLY HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE ON THE STEPS OF CITY
HALL BECAUSE THERE IS A BILL
BEFORE THE COUNCIL TO BAN BAN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT BUT THERE
ISN'T ANY SOLITARY THERE IS
RESTRICTIVE HOUSING.
AND WHAT TIFFANY CABAN WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IS THAT ALL THE
VIOLENT CRIMINALS THAT ARE
WITHIN RIKERS ISLAND BE ABLE TO
ATTACK ALL OF THE CORRECTIONS
OFFICERS AND THE NONVIOLENT
INMATES THAT ARE THERE.
AND WHEN THEY WERE TESTIFYING,
WHEN PEOPLE FROM CRENGS OFFICER,
BLACK BROWN MUSLIM TESTIFYING
HOW THEY HAD BEEN SEXUAL ABUSED
AND SEXUAL ASPAWLTED AND
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED, TIFFANY
CABAN RESPONDED WITH CHANTING
"TIMES UP, TIMES UP" AND CAUSED
A RUCKUS ON THE STEPS OF CITY
HALL.
>> Jesse: SHE NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED FOR ANY TIES TO THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT IN THIS CITY.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF SHE
IS GANG AFFILIATED OR BEING PAID
BY GANGS OR BECAUSE SHE IS JUST
DOING WHAT THE GANGS WANT.
SO IT'S JUST -- I THINK THAT'S A
PRETTY EASY ASSUMPTION TO MAKE.
IT SHOULD BE LOOKED INTO.
COUNCIL WOMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON "PRIMETIME."
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK Y